aujourd'hui c'est vous richard wehrli
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau que vous connaissez
éditorialistes correspondante ici en
europe en france et en europe du site
d'infos suisse blick votre dernier livre
la france contre elle-même qui est sorti
chez grasset et votre regard richert à
la fois d'ici et d'ailleurs nous
semblait utile dans le moment politique
que nous que nous vivons ici en france
depuis trois jours d'abord précisément
qu'est ce que vous inspire la séquence
que l'on vit depuis dimanche dernier que
dit-elle de l'état de la france mais
c'est une forme de révolution politique
qui est en train d'avoir lieu alors on
ne sait pas sur quoi elle va déboucher
mais il est manifeste et on voit à
travers les déclarations de fabien ou
celle que le président macron et tenter
de chercher une nouvelle formule mais
c'est plus qu'une nouvelle formule c'est
presque un nouveau système parce que qui
dit union nationale dira pouvoir
partager entre d'une part l'elysée
d'autre part l'assemblée nationale et ça
c'est tout à fait nouveau dans le
système français dont on connaît la
verticalité la toute puissance du
président donc à la fois révolution
institutionnelle et sans doute
révolution personnelle pour emmanuel
macron parce que la jupiter n'existe
vraiment plus ce qui est d'ailleurs
d'autant plus
remarquable au sens au sens notable que
le président a été réélu va s'il doit
faire sa révolution c'est contraint et
forcé qu'il arrête il a été réélu sans
qu'on sache vraiment quel était le
projet pour ce second mandat oui je
pense qu'il y a eu de sa part
deuxième mauvaise interprétation du
résultat ou ou peut-être deux fautes
politiques
la première c'est d'avoir pensé que
l'effet d'entraînement de son de sa
réélection sur les législatives seraient
identiques finalement à celui de 2010
est et on a bien vu que ça ne s'est pas
passé et la deuxième c'est d'avoir pensé
qu' une nommé une première ministre un
chef de gouvernement avant les
législatives dans l'espoir qu'elle
conduirait la majorité à la victoire
mais ça n'a pas marché non plus on est
quand même amené à se demander pourquoi
jean castex n'est pas rester jusqu'aux
législatives parce que très franchement
qu'il faut maintenant tout refaire
c'était pas la peine de nommer elizabeth
borne est ce que vous voyez dans les
résultats de ces législatives
précisément tant l'échec des manuels
macron où le succès de ses opposants
succès de ses opposants c'est indéniable
ça je crois d'un côté jean luc mélenchon
qui a sans doute fait vaciller emmanuel
macron même peut-être psychologiquement
il y est allé très fort dès le lendemain
de la réélection des vins de mâcon de
manière tout à fait inattendue alors
mélenchon il a perdu son pari de devenir
premier ministre mais il a gagné le pari
politique de faire d'eux de la france
insoumise et de la nuque une force
qu'ils allaient mettre en danger
emmanuel macron et quant à marine le pen
très beau succès politique d'une
stratégie que sur laquelle personne ne
misait vraiment street est opposée à
celle de jean luc mélenchon de pression
médiatique tout à fait elle est passée
sous le radar médiatique en quelque
sorte et ça a marché à cause de sa
proximité mais n'oublions pas l'effet
induit là pour le coup de l'élection
présidentielle eric zemmour avait pris
en quelque sorte toute la mauvaise
lumière la lumière de la haine de
l'obsession du grand emplacement et du
discours identitaire et il a permis
encore plus à marine le pen de se
dédiaboliser sachant qu'il faut préciser
à ce stade que les 89 députés
rassemblement national qui vont
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui faire leurs
premiers pas pour certains au palais
bourbon il ya un champ à champ politique
immense au sens du rassemblement
national et de ses élus alors pour
l'instant je crois que tous les
commentateurs français alors encore plus
pour les commentateurs étrangers ne
connaissent pas ces élus ils gens
connaissent peut-être une vingtaine 20
ou 25 donc ils sont familiers le reste
ils ne les connaissent pas donc on va
sans doute découvrir des élus qui peut
être ont des parcours un peu compliqué
rakic on va probablement trouver parmi
eux des gens talentueux mais marine le
pen va quand même avoir un vrai travail
j'allais dire presque de maîtresse
d'école à la tête de ses 89 députés
parce que 89 députés c'est beaucoup ça
apporte beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de
moyens mais aussi beaucoup de problèmes
et beaucoup d'ambition personnelle alors
emmanuel macron lisez bien sûr a perdu
sa majorité absolue est ce que vous
pensez que la france va vers à
l'immobilisme le blocage la crise
institutionnelle vous parlez dans votre
dernier papier pour blic d'un parlement
transformée en champ de mines oui parce
que la coalition enfin l'idée d'une
grande coalition voire d'une union
nationale elle est séduisante sur le
papier mais encore faut-il qu'elle
tienne c'est à dire que les chefs des
différents partis qui s'engageraient 1
soit d'accord 2 et les moyens de tenir
leurs troupes sur la durée aujourd'hui
je ne le vois pas et je pense que
personne n'y croit vraiment donc
emmanuel macron il lance cette perche il
l'attend au parti d'opposition mais la
tentation naturelle va quand même être à
mon avis de revenir vers une stratégie
qui consiste à diviser la ou l'autre des
adversaires et y en a un qui a priori
peut être divisé ses les républicains
emmanuel macron dans ce camp-là peut
lancer de nouvelles amarres avec des
postes ministériels
je vois plutôt l'a fait la phase
actuelle se terminer comme ça que par un
grand gouvernement d'union nationale
dont franchement il ne me semble pas que
veulent jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen sachant que celle qui en a parlé
c'est fabien roussel qui est communiste
dont les positions sont quand même pas
forcément macron compatibles alors c'est
d'un communiste en plus qui a toujours
fait je dirais du côté positif
l'argument de sa campagne c'est toujours
la france heureuse et c'est donc c'est
assez logique avec sa démarche politique
il a une force politique qui n'est pas
comparable à celle de jean luc mélenchon
ou à celle de marine le pen c'est eux
qui seront vraiment les tenants d'une
éventuelle coalition grande union
nationale et bien sûr christian jacob
qui n'arrête pas de répéter qu'il n'est
pas d'accord voilà donc ça ça ça augure
quand même des jours compliqués s'il
s'agit de faire des compromis pour pour
avancer pour éviter le blocage à quoi
peut ressembler des cons premier à la
française vous venez d'un pays richard
ou l'art du compromis est une discipline
quotidienne oui donc dans tous les
régimes parlementaires
la suisse est que la france est sans
cesse que la france varrault en tout cas
devenir pour le moment où est appelée
peut-être à devenir pendant cette
législature
dans tous ces pays le compromis est en
général habituel la coalition et quelque
chose d'habituel en suisse la coalition
elle est même obligé puisqu'elle est
figé au conseil fédéral qu'il compose
ministre de différents partis mais moi
je vois quand même deux obstacles en
france d'abord et ça dit beaucoup en
politique c'est les habitudes les
habitudes françaises ne sont pas celles
de l'union nationale pas celle de la
grande coalition alors vous me direz une
élection peut tout changer j'avoue que
j'ai quelques interrogations la deuxième
chose encore une fois c'est que pour
bâtir une union nationale en général une
union nationale c'est plutôt à la suite
d'un séisme qui peut être une guerre ou
un événement majeur est ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'une élection est un
événement tel que l'union nationale doit
intervenir j'en suis pas sûr donc ce
serait plutôt une grande coalition mais
la grande coalition il faut qu'il ya un
programme il faut qu' un accord et on
voit pas tellement sur quoi emmanuel
macron et ses adversaires aujourd'hui
les principaux peuvent tomber d'accord
en tout cas pas sur les retraites
notamment qui est un des gros morceaux
sur les retraites si la gauche sur les
retraites un accord est possible mais à
condition qu emmanuel macron retire
complètement son projet de réforme
autrement dit faut qu'il abdique de tous
ses ambitions des formes qui était
plutôt libérale pour aller du côté de
l'opposition s'il veut rallier les deux
grands partis français soumise et
rassemblement national la politique du
compromis est une politique d' humilité
je lisais sachets vos confrères du temps
ex confrère et ami richard est ce que
vous deviez que cette humilité
précisément au manque à la classe
politique française
d'abord je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
question d'humilité une coalition union
nationale ça suppose d'abord une volonté
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne en
allemagne les partis qui sont élus se
mettent autour de la table pendant
quelques mois ils ne sont pas humble
chacun ils défendent solidement leurs
positions mais par contre ils sont
d'accord pour arriver à un objectif
commun et ça c'est ténacité vers la
volonté commune je ne sais pas si elle
est présente en france elle et elle
n'est peut-être pas présente pour deux
raisons parce qu'en france il ya quand
même chose qui n'existe pas dans les
pays par le menton ses larmes de la
dissolution présidentielle inévitable
scénario inéluctable d'aucuns disent que
emmanuel macron faire ce calcul
politique très compliqué d'attendre que
ce soit trop le bazar à l'assemblée pour
faire porter le chapeau d'une éventuelle
dissolution ça ça doit être une
stratégie pour l'instant il a une énorme
difficulté c'est que la colère le rejet
qui cristallise dans une partie de
l'opinion dont on voit bien qu il l
explique en partie ce rejet il explique
le résultat donc c'est très difficile
pour lui de manier cette armée vous
savez une arme vous pouvez la voir sans
l'utiliser et l'avoir c'est déjà un
ascendant psychologique et donc la
dissolution via un peu tout compliquer
sinon s'il n'avait pas la dissolution on
pourrait dire que l'union nationale va
être forcé voir qu'une grande coalition
peut déboucher
avec larmes de la dissolution c'est une
tentation pour emmanuel macron de se
dire qu'il ya toujours une porte de
sortie et donc de faire moins de
concessions qu'ils ne devraient jamais
août un autre élément c'est que pour
bâtir un programme de coalition il faut
des partis bien installé or finalement
aujourd'hui le parti le plus faible non
pas en sièges mais en structurant
programme c'est le parti des manuels
macron parce qu'ils remontent
directement à lui alors on excluant pas
en suisse ça vous dit
un concept qui n'est si tout à fait en
excluant en excluant cependant la
plupart des régimes parlementaires
puisque les ce sont les partis qui sont
élus à la proportionnelle et qui
tiennent le long la lutte tout au long
de la législature en n'excluant pas
d'aller chercher des voies ou une
éventuelle union nationale notamment
avec le rassemblement national dont les
députés on le disait feront leur rentrée
aujourd'hui au palais bourbon est-ce qu
emmanuel macron ferez preuve fera preuve
de pragmatisme
ou est ce que ça pourrait être une faute
politique
pragmatisme il est obligé d'autant que
et on va le voir ces jours prochains
avec le sommet de bruxelles qui démarre
le sommet européen qui démarre jeudi il
y a quand même pour les mâcon d'autres
agendas que l'agenda intérieur il y à
l'agenda international
il termine la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne à la fin juin et là
ces jours ci il enchaîne directement sur
le g7 en allemagne avec les grandes
puissances
industrielles et ensuite le sommet de
l'otan de l'alliance atlantique à madrid
donc on peut penser qu emmanuel macron
il est tenté de calmer le jeu d'abord
parce qu'il y est obligé sur le plan
politique intérieur mais aussi parce
qu'il y a des dossiers internationaux
extrêmement pressant notamment la guerre
en ukraine et que pour ça il a besoin
quand même de s'y consacrer donc je
crois que c'est ce qu'il essaye de faire
en maintenant elisabeth bornes elle va
être une première ministre elle est
obligée êtes vous remis au ministre à
l'ecoute à moins que à moins que son
calcul soit plus cynique et dans ce cas
ce serait difficile pour madame bornes
c'est je la garde pour l'instant et dès
qu'une autre solution se dessine jeune
homme une un nouveau une nouvelle
première ministre elisabeth baume que
vous qualifiez de grands ratés des
manuels macron dans votre dernier
article auquel je renvoie ceux qui nous
regardent c'est sûr oblique point fr en
français pour pour pour nous autres
merci beaucoup merci ça va être très
difficile pour elle je pense que très
franchement
snap vous dit en substance je ne vois
pas comment il arrive à tenir sous
dessous va devenir une premier ministre
gestionnaire d'une grande coalition mais
ça m'étonnerait que les partenaires de
la coalition accepte le leadership de et
isabelle borne nommé par emmanuel macron
avant les législatives
donc là clairement pour reprendre mon
expression il y avait un raté dans en
deux mots à l'année qui politique arrive
à être désespérant tout revigorante pour
l'observateur je crois qu'elle est
extrêmement revigorante en tout cas elle
est extrêmement passionnante la grande
difficulté quand vous avez un oeil sur
la france et sur l'europe c'est que se
passe-t-il si steven le système français
se bloque parce qu'il a une vertu le
système français tout le monde le
critique tout le monde le juge
extrêmement verticale mais il est stable
et quand un président est là il peut
mener sa politique si ce n'est plus le
cas alors les voisins européens de la
france bonsant qui était dans le
contexte qui est ce qu'il est merci
encore un richard à très bientôt merci
juste après la pause pour la suite de
paris direct